இந்தஸ்ஸ்ஞ் அப்படியென்றால் மிகவும் முக்கியமாகப் பார்க்காங்க. போர்ட்டில்லாம் இந்தஸ்ஸ்ஞ் கூடியிருக்கிறது. நாம் ஏதோ தர்காப்புக் காட்டி விஷயத்தை செய்துவிட்டோமா, அந்தக் குலசைந்த அக்ஷன்தான்.
ஆனால் நீங்கள் தர்காப்புக் காட்டி விஷயத்தை செய்தால், அந்த மனத்தில் நீங்கள் என்னை யோசித்து செய்தாய் என்பதற்கு ஒரு விஷயமான தீர்ப்பு இருக்கிறது.
நீங்கள் தர்காப்புக் காட்டி விஷயத்தை செய்தால், அந்த மனத்தில் நீங்கள் தர்காப்புக் காட்டி விஷயத்தை செய்தாய் என்பதற்கு ஒரு விஷயமான தீர்ப்பு இருக்கிறது.
நீங்கள் தர்காப்புக் காட்டி விஷயத்தை செய்தாய் என்பதற்கு ஒரு விஷயமான தீர்ப்பு இருக்கிறது.
தீர்ப்பு காட்டி விஷயத்தை செய்தாய் என்பதற்கு ஒரு விஷயமான தீர்ப்பு இருக்கிறது.